monsieur le président monsieur président
oui matthieu delormeau m'a demandé un
service il veut déjeuner avec françois
hollande
c'était le le coup de gueule voilà
concernant léa salamé qui a déjà vécu et
pourquoi pas moi on vient de laisser un
message au président g le numéro de
manuel valls qu'on a communiqué en
région va appeler on va voir si on
pouvait des jeunes et manuel valls ou
vous jure que ce sont les vrais numéros
et on a le numéro de nicolas sarkozy
c'est son numéro il peut décrocher un
peu décroché trois ça serait énorme
eh bien on va avoir des problèmes des
problèmes c'est vraiment cru alors allo
monsieur premier ministre oui c'est
matthieu delormeau monsieur le premier
ministre je suis dans une émission de
télévision avec mon ami cyril hanouna
alors déjà merci d'avoir décroché
premier ministre cyril hanouna en fait
je vous explique c'est que matthieu
delormeau vous adore et il rêverait de
déjeuner avec vous donc on s'est dit on
va vous appeler le nom
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre
est ce que vous accepteriez des jeunes
avec me matthieu delormeau le bret qui
est et individus non mais
malheureusement rochette mois thierry
lalo n'a donc plus pour que ça soit lui
qui m'a vite d'abord à ben monsieur le
premier ça me fait plaisir
j'amènerai matthieu delormeau c'est lui
qui paiera d'accord avec son premier
ministre et nicolas sarkozy n'est pas
filmé c'est pas que vous voulez lui
parler ou juste mal alors allo allo
monsieur sarkozy allô oui bonjour
monsieur sarkozy c'est cyril hanouna
comment ça va vous êtes à l'antenne on
est sur des bidons en direct
[Applaudissements]
on va tous vous êtes qui monsieur me
suis dit ça ça monsieur moussaoui gbagbo
soir ça vous fait quoi dans la vie
vous voulez vous voulez déjeuner
et vous lui laissez un message précédent
au prisme monsieur le président monsieur
le président oui pardon de vous déranger
président je m'appelle matthieu
delormeau voiliers qui je suis oui lieu
merci beaucoup je suis dans une émission
de télé je suis dans une émission de
télévision en direct monsieur président
et mon rêve je les vois je n'ai pas
beaucoup de tories
j'irai très très vite mon rêve mais
c'est le président ça serait de déjeuner
avec vous au moins de prendre un verre
manuel valls le souhaitait également
mais je préférerais que ce soit avec
vous est ce que vous accepteriez écoutez
je vais y réfléchir je j'ai date de leur
modèle c'est un petit plaisir
j'ai demandé à marc antoine le vrai du
tout
[Applaudissements]
manuel valls était vraiment manuel valls
bah ouais
[Musique]